[Musique]
c'est pas de la faute de l'émission si
son compte parce qu'effectivement leur
sourire quand ya absolument pas d'eau on
leur dit blaise est absolument pas d'eau
pendant 30 minutes après quoi elle n'est
jamais très bon alors on rappelle que
justement on rappelle que des irlandais
sur m6 équeuter taille est justement
j'aime bien les deux maintenant même
mais koh lanta et bouge pas c'est plutôt
un enfermement dans la lettre rappelle
que ces glandes s'est basé sur l'entrée
vous êtes au groupe m6 m'a toujours
vives laissées dix mais non mais c'est
pas en plus je serai opéré demain mais
tu as où tous les noirs les traites de
crétins raffinerie traite de crète grèce
n'a pas brillé non plus par ton côté
aventurier à côté tu es tu étais pas
mais y'a c'est tout
alors vraiment une grosse ânerie bon
c'est vrai parce qu'un endurante c'était
moi de loin la plus en vue dans tous les
petits comme tous les petits fagots déjà
usé au départ est la plus endurant et si
j'ai pas brillé comme tu dit en gros
qu'on comptait sais que j'ai encore un
esprit de compétition j'en ai rien à
[ __ ]
en attendant c'est pas si facile tu
étais mauvaises que ce que tu as compris
des robots c'est facile tout attaquer
la phase très belle carrière pourquoi tu
t'attaques elle comme une carrière
percée centre de presse et pourrait
atteindre un sommet de près on voit
mieux c'est énorme tous comme le sourire
mais qu'est ce cas là qu'est ce qu'elle
a dit derrière pc sans on a l'impression
qu'elle disparaît non je te descendent
des annonces qu'après lui rennais vous
faire un manger la grosse commission si
vous avez trop fréquentes
[Applaudissements]